hey guys how's it going so I am in a
dressing room I'm already dressed so
thankfully I already have to get dressed
but I'm gonna be on the talk today on
CBS and really excited because they
could not have given me a better
question to answer we're gonna be
talking about George Clooney leaving his
honeymoon to go to comic-con basically
if my honeymoon wasn't at comic-con I
think I'd be a little pissed off so
anyway oh you're gonna be going on the
show the show was on here but we turned
it off so I could film a video yeah I'm
excited so Kirsten behind the scenes Oh
guess whose birthday it is tomorrow
we pretty I love the floor
tomorrowland in which he plays a hermit
inventor and i quote